Roxana Ruiz no puede ocultar su zozobra
desde ese maldito 7 de mayo del 2021 mi
vida
sigo viva Pero
muerta a la vez no la joven mexicana
sufrió una violación cuando apenas tenía
21 años su agresor amenazó con matarla
ella se defendió y en el forcejeo él
murió esa misma noche la policía la
detuvo sin activar los protocolos para
Víctimas de violaciones esta joven madre
soltera pasó nueve meses en prisión
ahora una jueza del Estado de México la
quiere enviar seis años y dos meses a la
cárcel por su excesivo de legítima
defensa es totalmente injusta la
sentencia de la jueza hacia mi persona
mensaje que manda el
las juezas lo que manda el sistema
judicial aquí que
las mujeres o tenemos de dos o estar
presas o estar muertas no el caso causó
una gran polémica entre los grupos de
derechos que ven injusta y
desproporcionada la sentencia Y es que
México es la nación de América con mayor
número de feminicidios al menos 11 cada
día según datos oficiales el viernes el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
prometió un indulto para Roxana vamos a
buscar la manera
de este ayudar
a la joven y si procede
me refiero a que
se pueda aplicar el indulto pues si hay
sentencias se nos va a facilitar y lo
vamos a hacer solo en dos de tres mil
setecientos cincuenta mujeres fueron
Víctimas de feminicidios en México
mientras Roxana espera apelar la
sentencia que le devuelva un anhelo de
vida